alors en vacances dans les landes
katherine et sa fille ont découvert cet
été le mouvement love on the rocks né en
angleterre
une véritable chasse aux trésors de
galets peints la main le premier j'ai
trouvé c'est celui ci donc en fait c'est
ma fille qui l'a trouvé sur la plage à
mimizan et derrière au dos on a été sur
le site du groupe facebook et c'est là
qu'on a découvert donc il y avait des
gens qui déposaient des galets sur les
plages dans la ville dans l'est dans les
parcs
séduite la famille a voulu lancer l'idée
dans la région depuis la création fin
août de la page facebook love and the
rocks région centre et aquitaine
les demandes d'adhésion sont en
constante augmentation
il ya un vrai engouement les gens
n'aiment pas beaucoup de temps pour se
promener avec le co vide et je trouve
que ça je pensais à nîmes leur balade
s'anime
ça donne aussi des motivations aux
enfants pour sortir ça égaye les
promenades des gens je pense tout galets
ramassés peut être remplacé ou cachés à
nouveau depuis un mois ce jeune couple
montargois explore les environs à la
recherche des meilleures gâchettes pour
leurs oeuvres
c'est une activité c'est une promenade
avec avec le confinement en plus on
avait qu'une heure par jour donc c'est
la petite promenade du jour était
sympathique ça donne un but une fois
leur galets dissimuler les participants
poste une photo sur facebook du lieu
avec quelques indices mais la balade la
peinture là l'imagination la recherche
on découvre des lieux aussi parce que
moi je suis pas de montargis de base et
ça me fait ça me fait découvrir des
lieux dans montargis
on sait complet on va dire si je n'y
arrive pas on envoie les photos et pour
les aider un petit peu dans les
aiguilles et un peu sur votre disposez
les galets chagall et vernis peut être
nettoyés et désinfectés pour permettre
de s'amuser en toute sécurité